in the West we generally expect
philosophy to come from books in the
East more wisely there's an awareness
that it may also come from other things
for example rocks this is a brief
history of a remarkable Eastern
tradition of philosophical rock
appreciation 8 to 6 ad Tang Dynasty leg
Tai jiang xiu province china a
middle-aged gentleman is taking a stroll
around a large lake on the Yangtze Delta
plain in eastern China when something on
its Shore catches his eye it's an
apparently trivial yet momentous
discovery a pair of oddly shaped rocks
this is perhaps no less than the
founding moment in Chinese petrol philia
this cultivated pedestrian is someone
special after numerous ups and downs in
his career as a state official including
periods of imperial disfavor in exile by
drew has finally made it he's been
appointed prefect of the nearby city of
Xu Zhu he also happens to be one of
China's major poets it's not a chance
combination of talents the ideal
administrator doesn't just know maths
and timekeeping in China he's meant to
be a man of learning and the arts many
of China's leading poets and painters
have careers in public service so struck
is by drew by these rocks with their
twisted angles and perforations that he
has them taken back home to Xu Zhu
soon after his return he sits down and
writes a poem about them a pair of rocks
by drew starts by admitting that the
rocks are not typically beautiful dark
sallow to slates of rocks their
appearance is grotesque and ugly they're
also covered in dirt and but grind with
smoke their cavities thick with green
moss he describes himself washing and
scrubbing them such as what is the value
of these unprepossessing specimens
Taoism which began as a philosophy in
ancient China before turning into a
popular religion cherishes nature and
it's evidence of nature's force that
Baiju welcomes in these rocks the holes
perforations and indentations sing
the patient mighty forces of the
universe which we should respect admire
an attempt to find harmony with the
ancient rocks are also a consolation for
ageing by who feels excluded from the
world of youngsters as he writes turning
my head around I asked the pair of rocks
can you keep company with an old man
like myself
although the rocks cannot speak they
promise that we will be three friends
thanks to by Jews enthusiasm and poetic
talent a wave of interest in rocks
follows 12th century AD northern Song
Dynasty wu wei district china me Fuu
another rather eccentric scholar
official has just been appointed as a
magistrate in wu-wei County on arrival
he has to pay an important social visit
he's been invited to meet and greet all
the other important administrators with
whom you'll be working they stand
waiting for him in the front garden of
the official residence but as he walks
towards them they're shocked at a sudden
breach of protocol on his behalf for
he's been stopped in his tracks by an
unusually large rock in the garden
instead of offering his respects to his
hosts me food turns and boughs
ceremoniously to the rock then addresses
it as elder brother rock and makes an
elaborate speech in its honor only after
fully expressing his devotion to this
amazing rock does me finally turn to his
flabbergasted hosts it was this story
that earned me through his soubriquet
crazy me and captured the imagination of
East Asia's painters for whom me Fuu and
elder brother Rock remained a favorite
image for centuries to come me Fuu goes
on to write a treatise on rocks that
enumerates for main aesthetic qualities
he detects in them shoe an elegant and
upright stature jus a wrinkled in
furrowed texture Lou or cracks that are
like channels or paths through the rock
and to the holes in the rock that allow
air and light to pass through in the
11th and 12th century Chinese northern
Song Dynasty the passion for collecting
rocks among scholar officials like me
Fuu takes off in earnest stones are
mounted on wooden bases and placed on
desks as constant sources of inspiration
the decorative stones become known as
Gong
spirit stones popularly mistranslated as
scholars rocks in english they're
peculiarly twisted shapes are admired as
evidence of the cui energy that is
believed to animate nature and the human
body alike any cultivated person is
expected to have an appreciation of
rocks they're valued quite as highly as
any painting or calligraphic scroll
during the Song Dynasty the most favored
rocks are quarried from the limestone of
ling be in the northern and hui province
ling be rocks a dark black and glossy in
texture
january 11 27 80 end of the northern
Song Dynasty kaifeng northern china the
imperial capital of china kaifeng is
under siege and about to fall to the
Jurchens
a nomadic people from Manchuria soon the
song Emperor huizong will be taken
captive and forced to abdicate while his
son
Quin Zhong will flee to the south to
establish a new Court and the southern
Song Dynasty China will be split in two
in his desperate final days of the
northern song the order is given for the
trees in we song spectacular Imperial
Garden at kaifeng to be cut down for
firewood and for its incredible array of
fabulous rocks to be pulled out of the
ground and used in catapults against the
invaders it's a sad end to what was
reputed to have been one of the most
remarkable gardens in world history the
Royal Park is that have been teeming
with striking rocks but Emperor Whois
ons passion for rocks has clearly caught
rather out of hand and explains his
neglect of security issues who is on had
in previous years appointed a royal
official to explore the whole of China
in search of precious rocks for his
garden tales are bounded of his
officials abuses it said that he
dismantled a bridge to let boats with
huge rocks pass by on a particular canal
a love of rocks appears to have hastened
the collapse of the northern song Empire
1450 Muromachi period Japan in 15th
century Japan a new type of rock garden
develops as with much in Chinese culture
the obsession with rocks has crossed
over to Japan
but has been adapted there in a
particular way in Japan the spirit rocks
are called souseki and the Japanese
favor much more subdued
with rocks and the Chinese in Japan
rocks are treasured for their weathered
appearance that exemplifies the worn
simplicity of the aesthetic known as
Webbie sabi in Japan the rocks are not
so much placed on wooden stands as
positioned in trays surrounded by sand
or water and a meant to evoke mountains
and corresponding lakes at several Zen
Buddhist temples and most remarkably a
tree ng in Kyoto the stones start to be
set in very minimal settings so as to
emphasize their qualities the raking of
the gravel around the rocks by temple
monks grows into a careful and precise
art there are various patterns ones
meant to use including the water pattern
of concentric rings or ripples like
those produced when a stone is dropped
in a lake the stormy water pattern of
haphazardly overlapping semi circles and
the continuous wave effect of parallel
or gently undulating lines the
originator of the East Asian reverence
for rocks
Baiju was well aware of how powerful a
love of rocks can become in his essay
account of the lake Tai Rock he speaks
of an addiction that some rocks can
bring about truly wise people should he
says restrict their rock worship to a
few hours a day when few of us spend
more than a few minutes a year looking
at a rock the advice seems less than
urgent indeed
the tradition of rock reverence has a
lot to teach us that a wisdom can hang
off bits of the natural world just as
well as issuing from books that we need
to surround ourselves with objects that
embody certain values were in danger of
losing sight of day to day and that some
of our most precious moments can be
spent in the presence of nothing more
chatty prestigious or costly than an old
stone ripe with years
you